hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
halte gibt es ein dekorations video und
zwar habe ich eine smoking torte
gebacken könnte eigentlich auch als
bräutigam trottel durchgehen oder mit
den rosen am rand auch als bachelor
torte aber bei mir ich würd sagen ist es
bei mir eine smoking torte und ich zeige
euch in diesem video wie man diese
ganzen dekoelemente herstellt ich habe
eine torte bereits mit von dort
eingedeckt und zwar war darunter eine
himbeer buttercremetorte die habe ich
nicht weiser ghanas bestrichen und mit
schwarzem von dort eingekleidet
ich
und jetzt kann ich die einzelnen
dekoelemente herstellen
jetzt möchte ich den kragen formen und
zwar nämlich dafür weißen von dort 251
gramm und damit er später schön
aushärtet und auch stabil bleibt muss
sich da etwas cmc pulver also zellulose
prüfe einen kneten
dann nämlich immer gerne so etwa einen
teelöffel auf 250 gramm von dort aber
ich starte immer trotzdem erstmal mit
einem halben teelöffel und dann merkt
man auch direkt die sich die konsistenz
verändert
also die konsistenz des von doors ist
jetzt etwas gummiartige also man kann
sich das so vorstellen man kann's besser
kneten und vor allen dingen wird dann
später eben schön hart und fest
jetzt soll ich das ganze dünn aus und
zwar zu einem langen strang der sollte
aber mindestens fünf zentimeter breit
sein
dann schneidet jetzt 1 4 cm breites band
zu recht
jetzt nehme ich einen runden gegenstand
ist ein tortenring mit 14 zentimeter
durchmesser und hpc so eine kleine linie
eingezeichnet und kann jetzt abmessen
fromm ein streifen hier lang der look
ist das einmal ansetzen oder nicht
verrutschen
ich schreibe jetzt aber so ein bisschen
kürzer ab mit einem trick gerat kann ich
jetzt noch ein paar nette ein stanzen
ist bespricht den balkan mit etwas back
trance pay back trend spray aber jetzt
sorgt es dafür dass der teig streifen
oder davon los streifen gleich etwas
dran haftet stelle ich auf einer platte
dann lege ich den streifen hier einmal
außen rum und knick jetzt die beiden
teile hier so ein bisschen nach außen
und mit einem von dort leider kann ich
das noch ein bisschen an drücken
jetzt lasse ich das einmal über nacht
trocknen
aber wenn man möchte kann man das auch
schon zwei drei tage vorher vorbereiten
aus der gleichen masse habe ich jetzt
noch knöpfe und zwar habe ich dafür so
eine silikonform das in verschiedenen
größen mit drin ohne silikon formen mit
euch jetzt mit etwas zucker stärke und
dann freue mich immer so kleine
kügelchen beim ersten müsste einfach mal
gucken wie viel masse benötigt und die
werden dann rein gedrückt
und am besten schließt man immer ganz
billig mit der form ab dann werden die
knöpfe nämlich am schönsten
und sobald ich die grippe eingesetzt
habe jetzt muss ich sie nur noch
trocknen lassen
mit weißem von da werde ich jetzt das
hemd noch machen und zwar weil ich sind
von dort dafür ganz schön aus das geht
immer ganz gut mit einer nudelmaschine
dieses weiße stück schneidig jetzt
dreieckig aus dafür muss ich wurde erst
mal die torte ab das sind bei mir 11 5
cm höhe
dann kann ich es mir wegnehmen
und bevor ich das jetzt ganz in form
schneiden nämlich in wachs papier und
zwar wenn ich dass die wachs papier
methode an
da streiche ich etwas kokosfett drauf
dann lege ich das hier an und zwar
bündig zur geraden kannte hier unten
wo jetzt schreibe ich die obere kante
bei 10 5 cm und schmerz erst mal recht
ähnlich rechteckig so
und am unteren ende markiere ich jetzt
von der mitte heraus ist jetzt bei mir
etwa 53 cm markiert hier unten eine ein
zentimeter dicke stellen
und jetzt kann ich von der außenkante
hier zur markierung abschneiden
und auf der anderen seite genauso
jetzt kommt da ein bisschen kleber drauf
die kann ich hier punktuellen auftragen
und dann verstreiche ich ihnen noch mal
mit einem pinsel
jetzt kann ich direkt an die torte
ankleben
einfach nur ein bisschen glatt streichen
dann setze ich hier nochmal ein
stückchen drin und schmerz unten bündig
weg und mit diesem geld also mit diesem
fahrrad schneide ich da jetzt noch einen
streifen rain
der hat so etwa 1 cm breite
wahrscheinlich nochmal die höhe zu also
11,5 cm und kann es dann direkt drüber
kleben
und damit auch schon gerade angeklebt
wird kann ich hier noch den mitte
markieren sieht man dann gleich nicht
mehr
die knapp dass ihr jetzt mittlerweile
ausgehärtet die kann ich aus der form
jetzt herausnehmen und steht damit ich
an kleben
und hier rechts und links kann so ein
paar markierungen setzen also praktisch
ins hemd rein
jetzt habe ich noch die naht vergessen
muss die knappe kurz nach 1 uhr
wegnehmen aber das ist gar nicht schlimm
die mache ich nämlich hier mit einem pre
grad
sie habe ich jetzt ein stück schwarz und
von dort mit etwas cnc prüfer vermischt
und dünn ausgerollt und schnell raus
jetzt auch ein langes band und dass wir
dann jetzt zu einer fliege geformt
und dafür rund acht zentimeter lang
hier oben steige ich noch ein kleines
dreieck ein
es kommt ein bisschen kleber direkt in
die mitte und diese zwei äußeren kanten
die knick ich ein bisschen ein und legt
dann zur mitte hin
und jetzt wird die schleife million
liegen jetzt die fliege mit etwas zucker
kleber befestigt
und damit man die fliegt jetzt nicht so
flach trick mit den fingern nämlich
jetzt so ein ganz flaches werkzeugen
messer wird zum beispiel auch coop eg
innen rein und drückt die innenseite
direkt an die torte fest
mittlerweile ist jetzt auch der krake
und fest und den löse ich jetzt erstmal
vom bug rahmen heraus und kann den
direkt an die torte kleben aber erst
drehe ich ihn um kann für mich schön
kleber draufklicken
da kann ich ihnen direkt auf die torte
setzen
jetzt wurde ich noch ganz schnell eine
rose für diesen smokie und zwar habe ich
hier rote modelle schokolade bereits
geknetet und dünn ausland komme so einen
langen streifen und dann legt man den in
der mitte um und hier knicke ich jetzt
nicht ganz also das soll so ein bisschen
locker sein und fangen jetzt hier an
aufzurollen und legt diesen streifen
aber immer wieder auch entfalten
und wenn die rose lang genug ist oder
groß genug ist schneidet man dem rest
weg dann drücke ich es und ein bisschen
zusammen und schreibt den rest einfach
nur noch ab und dann hat man eine ganz
schnelle 30 sekunden rose
ich habe die torte jetzt fertig
dekoriert und ich finde es zum beispiel
mal ganz lustig wenn man statt eines
normalen hochzeitstorte einfach mal so
eine bräutigam torte packt vielleicht
noch die braut mit dazu in ihrem
brautkleid und ich finde sie nicht so
voll geladen als das ist eine sehr
einfache torte und sehr schlicht
gehalten aber dennoch sehr stylisch und
wenn ihr die torte nachmachen wollen
dann wünsche ich ihr schon mal ganz viel
spaß dabei viel spaß beim modellieren
und dekorieren und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal bis dann tschüss